i have to know what it's like reading a
script like this that is so original and
unique and different and cool like what
is it like reading all that on the page
honestly i'm thank you for loving this
film because i honestly this is the type
of movie that i
wish for wish more of in hollywood and
in cinema things that we've never seen
before stories we've never seen genres
we've never seen non-linear storytelling
that we've never seen that is full of
heart and kindness and love
on the big screen that is not a part of
a franchise like this is what i dream of
and honestly it's such a testament to
the daniels because it was all on the
page we played we did a lot of
improvising and a lot of us brought our
juice and our little magical weirdness
to it but the heartbeat of it was on the
page and
most people don't even have scripts
these days
you know so you know it's it's really
it really is a gift of a project a gift
of a movie and the script really
reflected that everything that you said
uh when i first read it i i loved it i
cried i laughed so hard
i couldn't believe somebody
wrote a script like this
for a family of chinese families to be
specifically
uh
and and because i haven't done it for so
long
and to and for this to to
for the daniels to offer me this
opportunity to do to play raymond to to
play with these amazing actors i'm i am
forever and motivates grateful to them
uh it was just i mean like stephanie
said it was just a beautifully written
script and and i couldn't wait
to
to shoot it with them and and and it was
just you know i i
for the longest time this was what i
wanted
and uh and it was in the label available
so yeah i'm i'm extremely happy you know
well i'm glad you liked it because um
when i read the script i i couldn't make
heads or tails out of it maybe i'm kind
of old but you know in a way it's like a
lot of abstract things thrown into but
makes sense you know in the final in
like picasso this is modern uh
modern art
it's not the old-fashioned uh movies i
used to make like love is mini splendor
thing or a blood alley or all those old
movies i made that had a lot of form and
uh sort of you know stilted this movie
it goes all over the place but it it
it's just it's of art form that is being
invented now and thank goodness the
daniels did a very good job putting it
together and you can see the two of them
marrying together in their thoughts you
know and their feelings and then tell us
what to do
to heighten our performance and to tell
the story they want to tell you know we
are only artists we need that direction
we need their contribution and as a
result then we
we give forth even more uh
interpretation with our talent and i
think they saw the talent of all these
people and especially michelle
they recognize
what artistry is and then put that
artistry into one pot and that's what
you saw you know and
in that respect i hope you ought and see
what the asian american actors can do
you know because we love you people out
there and we love you for seeing our
films without you we are nothing so we
love you and i hope you love us and
forget and scrap this hatred thing what
for you know we're all americans you
know we contribute we love but get rid
of that deep hatred that makes you abuse
people and go out and beat old
old men but if they pick on me you
better watch
[Music]
um that was a out lead up to that bit
that was like went all yeah
i completely agree with everything you
said my last question for you guys
because i'm just about out of time i
love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of movies and shows
stuff you don't read in press notes or
hear about so for all three of you is
there anything that you think would
surprise soon to be fans of this movie
about the making of the movie
well i always say you know one thing
this is like my first very big feature
but they
a saying that i often heard or have
often heard since i've shot this film is
that every minute wasted on a film set
is like a million dollars out the door
however
i think what made our set so special was
that the daniels and our producer
jonathan wong we took time every morning
to say hi to one another to do a warm-up
together with the cast with the crew we
we always took time to make sure
everyone was cared for and on fridays we
would
hand out awards they were these little
trophies
trophy necklaces to people who are
working behind the scenes that maybe we
don't often recognize they could be pas
they could be someone who is doing the
recycling and and handling the greenness
of our set and
that i think people love this movie
because that love and kindness that we
practice with each other in making it is
real and it is very rare um
that's my favorite behind the scenes
because
you know and somehow we still pulled off
this movie like we took time to do
warm-ups and jumping jacks and tickle
fights and
we still somehow pulled this off you
know honestly if
the audience is going to be surprised by
how much stuff they see up on the screen
and how many days it took for us to
complete it
we it was shot for 38 days over eight
week period
and every single day
we had
tens of shots to do i mean there was
really
no time for hiccups no time for errors
and really it's a testament to what a
great producer jonathan wong and the
daniels and the entire crew was because
we all came to the set with only one
vision which was to do to make the best
movie we can and at the same time like
stephanie said have fun doing it
and it was just one of those rare
experience where you know you can have
both
it's so rare and and honestly and i
think the movie speaks for itself when
you watch it not only is it wild and
crazy and multiverse and so out there
but at the same time are you going to
see how much we love each other what a
great family we are and and and
the the amount of fun we all had
well to supplement what he's saying
we shot so much and uh
i would say only
one-fourth of it is on that screen they
could make another movie about the
camaraderie and the things we did the
outtakes would make an amazing film i'm
telling you you know the things that
they
i'm sure they had trouble cutting it out
if they put all that into another
so-called documentary the making of uh
or whatever i think
it would be a great thing i think i do
all the things that everything
everywhere all at once and then again
again
and again and again
did you hear that uh daniel boyce uh
make a sequel
i have to stop there but i really mean
it sincerely congrats on the movie loved
it i i hope it's a huge hit thank you
for your time
you